the part of the galaxy around us is an
area of the universe
explored sufficiently well by now
however
it's a really tiny portion of the entire
cosmos
nobody can say with confidence what
space objects may laken its depths
several million light years from the
earth
and most of them are likely to remain
undiscovered for quite a long
while but just imagine that several
radio signals
centered regular intervals from an
unknown source in space
are simultaneously detected on our
planet
many people would believe them to be
emitted by something developed by an
exceptionally advanced civilization
this was the conclusion arrived at by
scientists who encountered the
phenomenon of pulsars for the first time
july 1967 a series of passes was
detected with the help of a radio
telescope at cambridge university
by a post-graduate jocelyn bell they
emanated from a pulsar as yet unknown at
the time
and the results of the observations were
kept secret for several months
the object was initially designated lgm1
which stood for little green men the
name was given following the assumption
that these perfectly regular pulses
were not a natural phenomenon but
signals of artificial origin
supposedly transmitted by an alien
civilization
besides the team of scientists under
jocelyn bell discovered three other
sources of similar signals
the phenomenon took seven years to
investigate and the thesis advisor of
jocelyn bell's team
was later awarded the nobel prize for
studying this celestial body
which was subsequently dubbed bsrb1919
plus 21.
this pulsar was the first registered
phenomenon of its kind
its source was to be discovered several
years later in the constellation
valpecula
or little fox 2 283 light years from the
earth
information about psr b1919 plus 21 was
made public in february 1968
and by 1969 the number of detected
pulses of this kind
reached 27 and the term pulsar was
coined as the official name for these
objects
the first discovered source of this
signal was the object
dubbed wpo943 it was spotted by soviet
astronomers in the leo constellation
one of the most widespread assumptions
at the time regarding this discovery
was that all pulsars were in fact
ultra-powerful radio beacons of
extraterrestrial civilizations
and the pulsating signals remind one of
a lighthouse twinkling in the night
however it wasn't long before
astronomers agreed that the regular
signals were most likely emanated by
neutron stars
today it is positive that these impulses
originate as a result of a neutron stars
spinning
and are in fact thin beams of radio
waves
they're detected by the observer at
precise regular intervals
which accounts for the past appearance
of this emission
approximately 1790 pulsars had been
discovered by 2008
all of them were powerful sources of
impulse radio emissions
in space as for the pulsars closest to
us they are located several dozen light
years away from the sun
after pulsars were first detected other
pulsating sources of similar nature were
registered by astronomers
they were described as powerful flares
of regular intermittent x-ray emissions
thus they got their name x-ray pulsars
x-ray pulsars are also highly magnetized
neutron stars but unlike
radio pulsars which use their own
rotational energy
x-ray pulsars are powered by accretion
disks an accretion disk
is formed from material captured from
the companion star with the latter
eventually becoming a white dwarf with
all of its resources depleted
thus the mass and spin rate of x-ray
pulsars gradually build up during the
course of their revolution
as for radio pulsars they on the
contrary slow down as time goes by
for example the average radio pulsar
completes one rotation within the period
from several seconds to several tenths
of a second
with x-ray pulsars completing hundreds
of rotations within the same time period
one of celestial bodies of this kind was
discovered quite recently
and it is located rather close to our
system
the object was dubbed j1023 plus double
o 38
and its source caught astronomers eye as
recently as at the beginning of the 21st
century however
its passes reached the earth only in
2017.
this was the first ever millisecond
optical pulsar to be discovered in
essence
such celestial bodies are neutron stars
as well
with a rotation period ranging from 1 to
10 milliseconds
the spin rate of these pulsars is
several times that of regular pulsars
they form part of binary systems and
their spin rate
increases to incredible speeds is the
direct result of the pulsar pulling
material from the gaseous disc
produced by its companion star of a
smaller mass
it should be noted that when a neutron
star is in its active accretion phase
we see it as a source of x-rays when the
rate at which it pulls the material
drops
bright pulsed radiation can be seen in
the radio and gamma spectra
to date a few more pulsars of this
transitional kind are known to science
which fluctuate between the x-ray and
radio spectra in a similar manner
however it was the first ever
transitional optical pulsar with a spin
rate of this intensity
discovered by scientists the rotation
period of j 1023 plus double o 38
is 1.69 milliseconds which is 0.00169 of
a second
the object itself is four and a half
thousand light years away from us
the mass of its companion star is point
to that of the sun
it takes the pulsar 4.45 hours to orbit
its companion
star once to date the properties of
j1023 plus double o 38 have not been
investigated in detail
although it is likely to be a not very
massive neutron star
although the object was initially
considered to be a radio pulsar
in 2013 scientists noticed that its
impulses regularly subsided and it was
known to flare up
in the x-ray spectrum according to
scientists
this phenomenon may be accounted for by
the fact that the pulsar was at the
moment
in between the phases which looks like
the following
radio emissions occur when material from
the companion star is pulled to the
pulsar
but star wind does not allow material to
form an accretion disk
that is why the gas cannot heat up much
and looks brighter in the radio spectrum
in the second phase the stream of
material from the companion of j1023
plus double o 38 gets
stronger and forms an accretion disk
around the pulsar
the disc is in fact the source of
observable x-ray emissions
it wasn't long before millisecond
pulsating was detected in the optical
band of j1023 plus double o 38
as testified by earlier observations
carried out with the help of the swift
x-ray telescope
the neutron star was surrounded by an
accretion disk at the time
according to those in charge of the
studies the pulsar may have started to
flare up on the optical band due to
electrons in its magnetosphere
when these electrons speed was close to
the speed of light
in the future astrophysicists plan to
conduct additional observations
to study processes taking place within
this binary system
and now to the object of the kind
located furthest away from us that is
known to science
it is ngc 5907x1
a celestial body which is also the
brightest of all pulsars discovered by
now
spotted in 2017 this pulsar is an ultra
bright
x-ray source shockingly it releases as
much energy in one rotation period
as the sun produces in three and a half
years
earlier astrophysicists believed these
ultra bright
x-ray sources to be black holes however
after the discovery of ngc 5907x1
it became known that they may turn out
to be pulsars too
the object is located approximately 50
million light years away from our sun
as for its spin rate it is variable for
example
in 2003 the rotation period of the
pulsar was 1.43 seconds
whereas in 2014 it dropped to 1.13
seconds
just to compare if our earth were to be
able to change its rotation speed in the
same manner
a day on our planet would last just 19
hours
modern astrophysical models cannot
account for the intense luminosity of
ngc 5907x1
although scientists believe it to have
something to do with a powerful
multipolar magnetic field
that may be concealed within the pulsar
it will take even more complex studies
to find out the reason for the emission
of such staggering amounts of energy
just a few decades ago the phenomenon of
a pulsar was beyond any explanation
and today science is able to
differentiate
between this phenomenon and any other in
space
our civilization strides forward which
leads us to believe that even this
century may reveal a number of other
phenomena
unheard of in the past the universe is
like a giant canvas
with quite a few blank areas as our
knowledge about space builds up
the pattern on the canvas gets altered
too with regularly applied
changes it may soon turn into a fully
fledged map of our enormous universe
explored by man
[Music]
you